myths are the stories we tell ourselves
to explain the world around us and the
world within us
there is a conflict in every human heart
between the light and the dark between
good and evil and the light does not
always win sometimes the darkness
overcomes what Lincoln called the better
angels of our nature
well I cover all of the basics anyway
plot structure theme dialog and
characterization but I put them a mythic
depth into it for people and say did you
know that you're doing this mythic theme
and most of us don't but most writers
intuitively are tapping into one of
those wonderful old stories it's what
you do as a writer and we keep telling
the same stories over and over again
does anybody in your story actually make
a positive change in their personality I
think there should always be some
element of sacrifice and remember that
the word sacrifice means to make sacred
you've got a lot of people out there
with petty little gripes and they're
going to do it they're going to point
the finger because humans can sometimes
be pretty venal and tacky and mean and
so you give people a big target and ever
throw everything against it
love is at the center of so many
people's lives whether it's they've got
plenty or they don't
give us someone or something to be
sympathetic to give us some danger and
give us some kind of salvation or
resolution I like to just use the
initials SDS sympathy danger salvation
you shatter something in their lives and
they just go what the heck why bother
I'm just going to get mine and in this
instance of the myth it's very dark and
the whole world suffers because of their
loss ultimately there comes a time in
the life of the dark magician in their
career through the dark side that it
just doesn't work anymore and then all
that they have been holding back whether
it's aging you know someone who's had
the youth spell whether it's rotting
from the inside out whether it's being
slain by the tools that you used to slay
other people it eventually comes back
someone realizes they've got to change
in order to get what they want
so there's still a little bit of
selfishness in it but if they do it when
L if they do it with humility and
integrity it can work what is their path
and then do you want them to stay there
do you want them to grow into the next
level or are they going to be taken down
to a lower level and then try to
struggle their way back up or maybe
they're switching from one path to
another winners right history losers
write about love because the losers
aren't doing anything they lost in love
so they're the ones who write about love
and idealize it and how they think it
should be when you have someone
operating from the higher levels of
psychology and consciousness it's more
from the heart than it is from the loins
when we say falling in love note the
word falling another thing to keep in
mind is symbolism and we all use symbols
all the time it's once again just who we
are it's the oldest form of art right
look at your cave walls right
symbols going on for 70,000 years now
there are three levels of symbolism
there's the emotional personal level
there is the situational or
environmental level and then there is
the conceptual level take three levels
of opposition there's internal and then
there's opposition for those around you
family society culture and then on a
bigger level of stories there's the
opposition from the big outside you know
bureaucracies aliens you know tsunamis
a missed opportunity is a factor of
idealism because that opportunity is not
fact it's an opportunity it's a
possibility and on to that we can cast
all of our dreams and I think most of us
have had those moments you know the
glance across a room you're crossing a
street you look at somebody they look at
you and you go yeah and then you both
walk about do you think should I just go
stand on that street corner forever and
wait for them to come by again and some
people do but I think the thing about a
missed opportunity most at its core the
reason that it reaches us so deeply is
it offers that question what if and we
could see might that have been the
perfection that deep in our hearts we
are all striving for in my work with
writers we identify what mythic theme
their story is on and a subplot and then
work with archetypes for their
characters and symbolism and certainly
the power of the dark side which is ever
so much fun and could really add a lot
of depth to characters so I infuse my
work with writers with the ancient but
still very current and fabulously useful
tools of mythology so they can more
consciously use all those great old
classical story tools
oh yeah that's brilliant